hey it's Joey welcome to better ideas
have you ever wanted to have just like
uncomfortable amounts of energy do you
lack the necessary energy to carry out
basic daily tasks like going to the gym
doing your homework doing the laundry a
lot of people will tell me that they're
just too tired all the time even though
they might be sleeping like eight or
nine hours or they take a nap in the
middle of the day so if you're getting
enough sleep and you're still feeling
tired then what's your problem believe
me I've been there but I've gotten out
of that state and into a more energetic
state so many times that I know exactly
what causes me to get into that low
energy state and what I can do to fix it
so if you're interested in becoming
somebody who is just teeming with energy
like their body is a high of full of
caffeinated bees I have some invaluable
insight that will teach you how to
become one of the most energetic people
you know and how you will never be tired
again even when you want to go to sleep
you won't be able to go to sleep your
wife calls you to bed you say honey no I
gotta build something I got to be
productive so without further ado here
are five ways to increase your energy
throughout the day and yeah just be more
energetic number one you're gonna hate
me for this but number one is decide
that you're not tired if you've ever
played competitive sports I play hockey
for instance a lot of the time it's in
the third period I've played like quite
a hard game and I'm starting to feel
really tired
especially if I'm losing I just kind of
want to go home I'm sort of a sore loser
that way but most of the time I'm
sitting there and I tell myself no I'm
not tired I'm gonna go out there I'm
gonna play hard I'm gonna finish this
game strong and then I finished the game
strong sometimes being tired is as much
a mental thing as it is a physical thing
so if you think that you have a problem
with being tired all the time
you'll start to identify as somebody
who's tired all the time you're gonna
act that way so step one is to be a more
energetic person by believing you're a
more energetic person you have the power
believe me okay now to the more
practical tips tip number two is to not
over sleep a lot of the time people
think that if they're tired all the time
it's because they're not getting enough
sleep which absolutely could be the case
if you're not getting between seven and
eight hours of sleep you should
definitely think about doing so but if
you're getting like
eight eight and a half nine nine and a
half hours of sleep ten hours of sleep
and you still feel sluggish throughout
the day you're probably over sleeping
and I personally find that over sleeping
is far worse for my energy levels then
under sleeping that's not true every
time like it's better to get 10 hours of
sleep than it is 4 hours of sleep but if
I get six and a half I'm gonna be 10
times more productive than if I get 10
the next most important thing when it
comes to your sleep is to have
predictability in your wakeup time your
bedtime is important try to go to bed at
the same time every day I like to go to
bed at around 11:30 but if I want to be
teeming with energy I'm gonna wake up at
7 a.m. every single day without fail if
you start getting up at the same time
every single day it'll get easier and
easier to wake up at that same time
believe me so figure out a time that
works for you and stick to that
religiously you'll thank me later tip
number 3 is to get exercise every single
day and more intensive exercise every
other day as a minimum every single
video about energy you'll possibly ever
go to will tell you to get exercise and
it's no joke when I'm regularly going to
the gym you know 4 or 5 days a week I
the amount of energy I have is insane
and if you've been to the gym like once
or twice in the week and you're just
starting to get into it you might say
like oh I didn't really feel that big of
an energy boost in fact it made me way
more tired
stick with it it takes about one to two
weeks of consistently going to the gym
before your body starts to realize that
you're like oh man this guy is active so
it'll start supplying you with the
energy you need to go to the gym your
ancestors had to hunt down antelopes and
bison and things like that with Spears
they had to tire for legged running
machines out and then catch up to those
antelopes and kill them and here you are
watching YouTube this is probably like
the seventh youtube video you've watched
today don't click away human beings
thrive on being physical creatures you
have to become a physically active
person that way your brain and your body
will give you the energy you need to fit
that lifestyle tip number four is eat
better and
is another cliche comment but I'm
serious guys like some of the best most
effective advice is the stuff that
you've heard a thousand times before
your body is a temple and you have to
put the right church goers and your body
is a car and you have to put high
quality gas and oil in that car in order
for it to run optimally I don't even
really like this everything you put in
your body matters you don't need to
follow a super fancy diet in order to
feel good in fact if you're just
starting out I wouldn't recommend trying
a crazy diet because you're probably not
gonna stick with it probably taste like
crap and you're just not ready for that
kind of thing so I've put together a
couple notes here that are just some
basics that will make you feel a lot
better if you're not doing anything so
if your diet is crap the number one
thing you can do to fix your diet is to
cut out sugar not cut it out completely
but like dramatically reduce the amount
of sugar that you're having it's like
the least complex carbohydrate you can
possibly eating something sugar packed
is like throwing a lighter into a
campfire and then watching it and you're
like oh wow that was kind of cool but
now it's over that's what happens when
you eat a doughnut it's like it's
useless the second thing you can do is
reduce the amount of carbs you're having
or a cheap carbs at least so a cheap
carb is like a doughnut a cookie usually
things that have lots of sugar and are
highly processed and switch them out
with more complex carbohydrates like
brown rice potatoes and stuff like that
and on that note try to reduce the
amount of carbs that you have in general
and start replacing it with good fats
like the stuff you find in coconut milk
avocados definitely don't do keto if
you're just starting out it's a really
hard diet to stick to do it if you're
more serious about weight loss or
something like that or bodybuilding but
just for now try to reduce the amount of
cheap carbs start eating some more
healthy fat more protein heavy things
meat beef fish I like here Johnny you
have two options you have beef or meat
the only thing to be careful of is when
you're having a lot of fat it's usually
pretty calorie heavy so just make sure
you're not eating at a calorie surplus
unless you're actually trying to gain
weight there are thousands of videos on
diet don't listen to this one the other
thing you can do to increase energy
levels through your diet is to eat more
dark
Green's it's a pretty accurate rule that
the darker and richer the color of a
vegetable the more nutrients it has this
isn't true all across the board but
start substituting your little pathetic
iceberg lettuce with spinach or kale
that will give you a lot more nutrients
and make you feel better and finally
drink lots of water you know there's
tons of debate whether you should be
drinking a gallon of water a day or it's
six cups of water a day six cups is too
low and a gallon is probably if you're
an average person it's probably too much
I drink about three liters of water a
day it works for me I'm on creatine so I
have to like drink more water than usual
I'll drink this whole thing which is 2.2
liters and then I'll probably have like
various other drinks so I probably drink
a little over three liters of water a
day which is pretty close to a gallon
and I feel great I feel so good my fifth
and final tip is to perform then my
fifth and final tip is to perform a
mid-day reset so naturally as human
beings will have a sort of ebb and flow
of energy all throughout the day
you know sometimes we'll feel super
hyped and then we'll come down from that
you can't avoid that you can't be like
100% all throughout the day unless
you're on cocaine actually even people
on cocaine they crash unless you're on
meth people want people on meth they go
for like 48 hours I personally have a
pretty consistent crash around 2 to 3
p.m. every single day and this is when
my motivation and my overall energy
levels really start to and I'm usually
tempted to either take a nap browse
Reddit do something super unproductive
instead of doing that I've learned that
the best possible thing I can do is one
of these three things go for a short
walk meditate or go to the gym so you
might be thinking these things aside for
meditation aren't really relaxing they
actually cost you energy so why would I
go do something physically strenuous if
I'm feeling tired well my friend
remember this law that which Kostis
Energy giveth energy if you're feeling
tired go do something that expends a
little bit of energy I
why this works or what the science
behind it is the amount of times that I
felt tired in the middle of the day so I
decided to take a nap and then I got up
feeling way more tired than I was before
I took the nap is an uncountable amount
of times it's an infinite amount of
times but the amount of times that I did
something sort of like I had to help
somebody move or I went for a little jog
or I had to chase a raccoon out of my
apartment that's never happened I'm
hyped after that I feel really really
good so next time you're feeling tired
in the middle of the day make that the
time you do something physically active
remember that that which costed energy
giveth energy and you'll be good you'll
you'll be so good that's it for this
video thank you for watching I hope you
enjoyed these tips if you are not
subscribed yet make sure to hit that
subscribe button and if you want to see
a video like this ever again if you want
to see my face ever again you will hit
that Bell icon because YouTube is so
messed up these days if you don't hit
that Bell icon you won't get a
notification when I release a new video
so you might as well not be subscribed
in the first place so make sure you hit
that Bell icon otherwise this could be
it we'll see you later
if you find this sort of content really
helpful we have a Facebook group down
below and the Facebook group isn't down
below but there's a link to it in the
description down below if you click on
it it'll take you to the group my plan
for this group is to have enough people
from my youtube channel to be on there
talking about self-improvement talking
about little productivity tips and stuff
like that helping each other out
building a community that has nothing
but benefits for you so if you want to
be the greatest version of yourself
you'll click the link in the description
join the Facebook page join the
community
thanks for watching and we'll catch you
in the next video baby myself bring it
back from the brothers killing in an
don't even need a go end up the rest I'm
just throwing up the rest baby stick it
to the silicic we brother one step